i know
that why maybe somebody he he ugly but
i still yeah i already know my aim
i got a wife yeah yeah you wiped up
yeah remember there was a whole kodak
thing about how he prefers light skin
light-skinned girls big lights and girls
are easier
easier to control i guess something like
that
are you on that
i ain't gonna lie what do you say i'm
already black only no black
right that's what he said yeah ain't
gonna lie i can't have to
cut like i know i'm black right
i'm black yeah black is beautiful though
man so i know if
if i black we'll have a black baby so
i ain't with that what come
already black so i can't
no well i mean this is an interesting
thing
you know i mean like so if you have a
baby you don't want your baby to be the
same complexion as you
why it's a once in a lifetime thing
what do you mean like it's a dark shade
yeah nah i can't
i can't have is your mom same shade as
you nah
she's hannah moonlight karma mocha okay
so your dad is darker
yeah okay nah that's
oh what you talking about i'm black you
see that boy
so your dad is actually darker yeah yeah
okay have you has your mom ever said
that she doesn't want her grandkids to
be nah
okay cause i remember i interviewed uh
you know amara lenegra
you know what that is she's all loving
hip-hop i'm gonna show you
sad but it's the truth i've heard it
many many times um
and we are treated differently why she
sounds like she's screaming all the time
because she dominican all right
because we are treated differently but
she's dominican like all the all the
words
differently like it all finished going
upward it was not a joke i said what i
said
okay no because if it's don't be
dominican on me like you got the screen
no but it's the dominican reflection you
know it's so aggressive
a lot of latinos don't want my kind
mixed into their family because they
didn't want to better the race
and better the race means more european
features
that sound like some clouds and a lot of
sound that's a clown
that's that's some clown straight up
straight up but but you're saying that
you don't want a kid
that that's going to be your complexion
but don't
don't you want don't you want your kid
to look like you though that's what you
just said
he calls one thing clown stuff which is
exactly what he's
putting out there and he calls it clown
but he says the exact same thing
he didn't think this through i don't
think
i'm not mad at him for the comments he
made i'm not even mad at his person
despite thinking what he said was very
um toxic
what he wants is not necessarily a bad
thing it's why he wants it
right like if you want to date out of
your race or that's not a problem
you know what i mean even wanting to
date your own race that's not a problem
the reason understand why the why is
always the motivation behind it's like
to him black is ugly killing someone
isn't inherently wrong why you kill them
is what really matters
are you killing them in self-defense
well in that
case killing them is justified and
therefore morally fine
are you killing them for revenge now
we're in a different place but at the
end of the day it's violence and all
violence is bad
abba that's that's not that can't be
true but anyways in that same token
why you want certain things also matter
does that make sense so
when he says i don't want my kid because
i don't want a kid to be same complexion
as me
right well what's wrong with that he
says
oh he starts to fumble a bit you can see
he hasn't thought it through
to him black is ugly yes to him black is
ugly yes that's his reason
yeah the reason is that black is ugly
and he wants to
whiten his gene pool yeah
this is a common thing for a lot of
people a lot of people have internalized
issues in those regards with
their looks their features like i know
some people who don't want to date
some person's same race because of the
gnosis that are
common i know some people who don't want
to deal with in the same race because
they don't want their kids to have
slanted eyes a lot of these things are
pervasive in our society and they're
unhealthy
the idea that you're going to try to
genetically
engineer the right child and eliminate
partners based off what features that
chama have to me
seems a little frightening does it not
to you because it shows to me that we're
dealing with self-hatred when we're
making with choices we hate our own
insecurities
and so we're letting our insecurities
drive what kind of partner we're looking
for and therefore also what kind of kids
we're going to produce
but what happens when we don't get the
kid that we want how does that
insecurity manifest with them once you
do everything you can
and your kids still get slanted eyes how
are you going to interact with them
where did he learn that his dark skin
was somehow less attractive
that's the questions that i'm interested
in because he didn't come to that
himself he said his mom never said
anything like that maybe he's that dude
maybe society did we don't know
he doesn't even he's not even aware of
how bad what he's saying is but he
didn't do that introspection i don't
think at that age
he did that introspection and stuff like
that or whatever what not so yeah no
he didn't he didn't think dude that's
why i was saying he didn't think this
through because
i don't want to be with a black woman
because my kids gonna be black as
so to him it's ugly and amara la negra
she has a point
it's true what she says especially she's
from the dominican so
that that that that there's that in
there there's there
people think like that and she's been
around that you know and that's what
she's repping when she's repping
but yeah he doesn't even know why no he
just he's just saying stuff i
even out of like at your teen years
just right after 18 years you still say
stuff because you say stuff you think
you're right
and there's a truth and you say stuff i
was like that you just say stuff you
think you didn't think it through
you didn't introspect you didn't look
beyond what you know
right and that's what's going on that's
a result of that he doesn't even know
why he's saying that
he doesn't even know how bad it is how
bad it is where it's rooted
i would say that yo what you just said
is racist you wouldn't even understand
because he didn't introspect
but it's a form of racism he didn't
self-hate it's even the idea that like
the other guy said
when the other guy said uh i want a
darker skinned woman because she's
easier to control
i want a light-skinned woman because
they're easier to control yeah likely
like those kind of free
that's prejudice yeah that's prejudice
and it's just you
liking light skin is one thing why you
like them because you want to control
them
god damn that's toxic that's toxicus
yeah yep yep so that because then it it
shows
where our mindset is and if we have
these preconceived notions what kind of
decisions how are we interacting with
these people
that kind of stuff matters too so look
again this is not a simple solu
discussion and it's not because i'm
saying this that you
wanting a white woman is inherently i'm
not saying doesn't care
right away the case i'm saying
understand why where it's from
we are not just born like this this idea
that we just oh we're born to like
no because preferences change over time
some of us want someone thinking now but
changes later on right
societal preferences change over time
big booties are in now they weren't in
before
they weren't they weren't they weren't
they weren't at all
at all in the 90s my god it was all
pamela anderson terminal electro no
booty yup
no booty there was a time when pale skin
was very seen as attractive yup even
obesity things change over time
because they're different indicators of
status and value in the 60s and
60s and 40s and 60s 50s 60s moment was
thicker
yep yep so it left and then now it's
better
so all these things change and we have
to understand why they exist and what
they're meant to represent in our
current time
in our landscape and there is no doubt
in my head that there's a lot of people
who operate with the ideas that
blackness is inferior i have heard black
men
say oh blackness is disgusting
yup dead ass straight up i've heard
asian people say
asian features are gross i've heard why
people say
if my kids turn out white i will be
supremely disappointed
yup this is everywhere yup man i i kid
you not i literally heard a white girl
say to me
man if i like kids i don't even think i
want a parent
i was like what is he talking about
you're gonna orphan your kids because
they didn't come out the right shape
but this stuff and she didn't say
maliciously she didn't mean it
but she doesn't recognize how
toxic some of her ideas are and if she
does that
if she has white kids imagine what she's
gonna be like raising them having that
in the back of her head
yeah yeah
looking at those kids i wish you were a
different shade this is a mistake
so you're not maybe not gonna say that
to your kids but the way you're gonna
raise them is gonna show up that yeah
if i didn't want no kids and i raised my
kids like i didn't want them yeah
it's going to show yeah there's plenty
of parents who have their kids by
accident
but they had dreams and they've taken on
their kids all the time yeah
you don't think you would do that in
this context of course you would of
course
so all these things matter and i think
whenever i bring up this topic people
like i like what i like and they all get
so defensive i don't give
what you like i'm just saying let's
discuss why that's it
discussion not condemning i'm not
condemning him either
but we need to have smarter talks that's
all so
yeah that's pretty much it for today's
video we want to hear your people ready
for smarter talks yeah
people get so that's a whole other story
right now if people are ready to have a
smile
because you you can't want to have it i
like what i like that's not what he said
i like what i like
you're not gonna shame me that's not
what i'm saying because i like what i
like
gross people are not ready for avocados
[Music]
me